ERIK DEMAINE: I mean,
there are a couple
of different approaches
to teaching this class.
One is to make it fun.
I really like to make
material as engaging
and as accessible as possible.
So, especially if you have
relatively little experience
in algorithms--
you've just taken
6006-- and some of
these algorithms
get really complicated.
And they're hard to
understand and it
makes you wonder, how did
they ever come up with that?
So I like to talk about that.
In some of the
lectures, I'll kind of
give an idea of how they
might have gotten there.
It's like, oh we could start
with this really simple step.
It's really inefficient, but
at least it solves a problem.
But then we have this extra
thing and this extra thing,
and eventually you get to
the really fast solution,
so it's less of the mystery
of how you got there,
or how the original
researchers got there.
And I also try to
remind students,
especially in the harder topics,
that this is not easy stuff
and you should think
about it a little more.
Do the problem sets and you'll
learn it-- figure it out
at a deeper level.
But a lot of this
material is hard,
and I think being honest about
that makes it more reasonable.
Students don't feel
bad for thinking
that it's hard, because the
first time you learn it,
it is hard.
But the whole algorithmic
way of thinking
of setting up a problem-- what
should the input and the output
be-- and then thinking about
all different solutions for how
to fill in the middle I think is
a really powerful perspective,
and it can shape pretty
much your entire life,
but especially if you're
doing computer science.
It's a really useful
way of thinking,
and I've gotten lots of
letters later from students
where they're doing some job,
some computer thing and they
ran this problem and then
they discover-- and then they
looked back at their
notes and said,
oh, this is the right data
structure I should use now.
And they solve it, and
they tell me about it.
And it's kind of exciting to see
years later the way of thinking
and lots of the
solutions and techniques
you see in this class really are
useful out there in the world,
so it's a useful class to take.
It's a relatively hard class.
The exams are challenging.
We try to make them
not super challenging,
but it's hard,
especially whenever
creativity is involved.
It's hard to do that
live in an exam.
So students may not perform
super well my class,
but still they get the
idea that this is a way
to approach problems,
and they understand
some of the techniques.
And over time, they can
fill in whatever holes they
left behind, and
say, you know, it
seems like a problem where
dynamic programming would
be really useful.
It's time I really learned
dynamic programming.
Dynamic programming is one that
we actually teach both in 006
and 046, because it's
really conceptually weird.
It's actually really easy
once you understand it,
but getting to that point of
understanding is really tough.
So we spend a lot
of time on it so
that the ideas-- and more
exposure you get to it,
the clearer it will become.
I think by the end of 6046,
they have a pretty good idea.
But if not, years later,
if they come back it,
I'm sure it'll be a lot
easier this third time around.
So a lot of these
concepts are-- I mean,
the ideas are actually
really simple.
They're just hard to shift your
mind into that kind of mindset,
but once you do, things
become really clear.
So hope is, by the end of
the semester, they get there.